hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play y night
ah summer on my headphones huh yeah okay
I'm okay now all right so you guys
informed me then I'm an idiot but what
else is new you also inform me that
there's another room over here that I
missed hmm yes I think I will go over
there now
Oh wha Oh fire well do that bout at
something that's act like nothing did it
go [ __ ] you oh my god okay nobody told
me that there was like fighter monsters
what the hell was that you have to
remember Aaron I know good lordy Lou
those that was knows where were they
before where the hell were they before
uh-huh when worth what the hell did this
game get fire monsters jeez oh yeah fire
monsters you can think of a worse
combination to scare the bejesus out of
me I was like you know I thought it was
a monster then I thought oh fire no no
monster
oh definitely monster monster not
monster monster definitely monster okay
so there's another room in here wait a
minute no not in here ah not in here by
over there there it is I see it I see it
I see it I see it I see it I see it I
see it IKEA
oh yeah your rat clinic link it don't
work
gasoline batteries I need those like a
lot hmm let's see if I can recollect
don't tough happened you're just like a
hack like a lot anybody know I'm talking
about or am I just being obscene here
okay so I got the gas all right they
were gasoline in the drums back over
yonder way yonder Vey hello do
Chiz McGillicuddy you heard what I said
and you did it huh ah made it flawless
oh come on I forgot her hut dirty hot
dirty do yay
alright moving forward away from the
monsters of doom and clearing my path
into fame fortune I don't know Andy into
all of your hearts okay no nevermind
you'll hate me okay so I need to fill
this with it oh yeah I need to fill this
with okay use it that way how about
you're a dick
how about oh now I feel the gasoline can
so I can get light I'm going to go in
here I'm a stick the nozzle in you stick
that nozzle in me I'm gonna break your
head okay so is this where I'm supposed
to stick the nozzle in nope nope no no
where did the note say that I was
supposed to stick the nozzle in hmm you
think I'd know this T fella can fill
container next to generator with
gasoline the container right the
container mmm
well there's gotta be it it's gotta be
one of these things I remember another
custom story that I played one of these
little things was a douche but they were
eventually the thing I was supposed to
use it on so no oh no you're gonna be
like that you're gonna be on a oh dammit
where do I now where do I stick it in
come on was it that's an a-hole just
another hole in the wall mmm okay I'm
just gonna oh hey
aha don't know how that worked but
whatever clink Clank clink clunk I
should try again okay
[Applause]
yay like ah babysitters a balloon enough
of the bad singing now let's ha 100 oh
the music is tricky kind of catchy but
freaky at the same time holy baloney
what was that turn turn turn turn turn
turn turn
aah get away water douches don't know no
none
darn out on ok so there are now
quote-unquote lights in this area look
like whoa doesn't help me much I better
just carry on my wayward son there'll be
peace never could you're gonna die that
should be how that song goes shut this
door New York see that's kind of
freaking me out here just a little bit
just a little bit
that music is I mean Tana I don't know
lock is broken oh I don't know oh hey
here we go
ok so through here into the dark room
lovely crouch down cuz that's not a [ __ ]
hi hey hey hey is gonna keep doing that
now you douches you dicks
you're a dick you are dick you are
exactly dick so thank you for that he
was taking notes his notes for the next
session
what if ok I miss that prolly wasn't
important or it was exceptionally
important either way
pause the video if you didn't catch it
what's going on here what's going on
here
this doesn't feel right this does not
feel right no no no who keep me out of
here I want to be here I don't like this
what are that oh shut up shut up
whoo God get away who's that hi
oh hello all right why am i walking
towards the monster okay good I can't go
that way
uh-huh thank you thank you so much Hey
look batteries yay yay oh look they're
buddies ha ha she is a murderer who is
if looks could kill
I was supposed to be funny
damn it never mind you screwed up my
joke alright oh good there's an arrow
pointing towards my demise I'm guessing
oh hello
we all will wear white why okay I think
I'm starting to really get close to the
holy crap
to the extreme depths of insanity uh-huh
yeah
who is doesn't look so bad Oh deafening
voices echoing in my mind I had always
wanted to be a fireman one looks me down
with a face darkened from soot are you
alright son he asks I know I will never
be alright again where there are objects
in the other rooms that I could zoom in
on and reminisce about you know maybe
it's arm ring uh that's a lot of
memories now you have my permission to
cry anybody anyone know what I'm talking
about
no alright scream then I'm just gonna
carry on carry on I'm gonna cry on my
keyboard ear was not expecting that to
actually work now okay
sure haha oh my god what the hell with
that
jeez quickly quick it's Qui Qui Qui
oh come on how is this even fair screw
you ooh whoa huh I saw something I hate
this part
this is the worst episode oh I hate it I
hate it I hate it
Oh God oh I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't wanna know on it oh man I'm
scared but I'm having a good time at the
same time so I don't know I don't know
how to feel right now
okay I'm more batteries I like this I
really really really like this custom
story it's Oh God Oh
why good good no no ahead I changed my
mind
I hate this custom door no I really do
you like it it is exceptionally well
made of the atmosphere is just
mind-bendingly terrifying hmm oh okay
uh-huh what that way how did I huh why
is that one rivet oranger than the
others where the hell am I wheelchair
monster [ __ ] you Oh God Jesus Gustav my
word turn cheese on a cracker goodness
gracious oh my oh oh
uh-uh scible terrifying thing I've ever
seen in the matter I do huh oh who cares
about your problems man oh shut up man
yeah good mm-hmm
so you're the douche oh god I got stay
over here well actually that's pretty
good I don't want to go out there okay
buddy mari you just go die now
UK whoo-hoo okay all right here's my
prediction the doctor lady is the evil
one the doc that doctor was all right
you what happened to Patrick aha God
nailed it
yeah [ __ ] you weren't a doctor from the
start
yeah if you I wasn't a real doctor but
you can't deny I was a good doctor too
oh you were the best oh but I can't just
dissent someone conducting experiments
on me oh it was so devoted oh why are
you telling her doesn't really matter
you will forget again okay me you forget
a girl to make you forget you don't even
remember Patrick was your
it wasn't my friend my friend so I was a
doctor here it doesn't matter who you
were
what Madison who I want you to be uh you
know who you are a giant [ __ ] yay yay
yay time for you to wake up David time
for you to remember time for you to
remember David okay
is it really honest it remember o clock
sorry I lost my watch alright so now
remember 30 must be close to the end
how is in the other we're almost out of
time
ergo like I always like to do even if
it's gonna result in a two minute
episode I would like to keep all the
ending constrained in one episode so I'm
gonna cut it here thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you
good you know what you know what I lied
I lied I'm out of finish the ending in
one episode good screw it
come on bring it on [ __ ] oh there you
are thank you it's good ha ha I think
y'all out J night I faked you out I
faked you out and if ends up being too
long I'll just cut it up I'll just cut
it up right Danny there what that wait a
minute do you have any memories you
don't want to forget can you hear the
melody of truth have you ever broken
your promise
a man was talking endlessly about
life-changing experiences I was making
him almost laugh then he suddenly began
to think about it promise
hey wait a minute all right how much
longer how much longer until the inning
I'm not I'm not actually that close am I
I'm necklace another close mi all right
so now I'm good ha ha ha I'm just toying
with your emotions I am the puppet
master for your your emotion your fear
and anxiety okay so anyway yeah well
we'll finish this up later so thank you
again for old for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done it as always I will see you in the
next episode bye bye
too heavy to lift me Oh impossible could
it be this dick
[Music]